morocco's prime minister will have a
tough job holding on to power in these
parliamentary and regional elections the
conservative justice and development
party has headed the government for 10
years it came to power promising an end
to despotism and corruption
but the party has struggled in a system
where the king appoints most of the
cabinet and directs policy
many young people have registered to
vote for the first time wish them luck i
ask for their strong participation and
to get involved in politics because it
affects everyone's daily life and their
children's future and all kinds of
services
the constitution was reformed after the
2010 arab spring supposedly to give more
power to political parties but many
people are skeptical whether elections
make much difference to how the country
is governed
the pjd party has done nothing they made
promises but when they came to power
nothing happened they haven't even given
an argument for why they haven't honored
their promises
i hope this vote god willing will lead
to greater care being taken of the young
and give them a chance to prove
themselves in service or work for our
beloved country
a new method of allocating seats makes
it almost impossible for big parties to
gain a majority while much smaller ones
will be represented in parliament for
the first time we will have more
balkanization both in the local uh the
parliament and with which means that
political parties will find it very
difficult to build coalitions and to
find consensus when you have a large
number of political parties leading for
example a municipality or a government
with seven or eight political parties
there are 32 parties running in the
election it's hard to pick out any
significant policy differences between
any of those standing
once the votes are counted the haggling
for influencing the coalition will begin
and it took three to four months after
the last elections for a new government
to emerge but whoever ends up leading
the parliament here will be expected to
implement the king's policies what he
calls a new generation of reform and
projects and a new model of development
bernard smith al-jazeera rabat